what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to jada pinkett smith
breaking will smith's heart for four
minutes straight um i hear a lot about
this couple in the manosphere they
really like do not like them together
and before i started watching like red
pill content i thought they were
adorable so it'll be interesting to see
if i
like what i think of like the negative
side of their relationship because i
really haven't seen a lot of this before
i start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos and every time i post
like you'll get to see it
um
i'm also going to england soon so that's
like every subscriber really helps the
channel so if you guys wouldn't mind i'd
appreciate it all right you've been on a
hell of a journey with me
yeah you know there's people's feelings
involved right
right you know
it's healing that needs to happen
absolutely so what happened jada okay so
i think it was about four and a half
four years ago
um
started a friendship with august
and
we actually became really really good
friends
and it all started with
him just needing some help
you know
me wanting to help his
health his
mental state and we found all those
different resources you know to
help pull them through
and
from there you know you and i were going
through a very difficult time yeah
that particular point in time it was
indefinite yeah i really felt like we
could be over yeah no we were over and
then what did you do jada well you know
i think
from there
you know as time went
you're fumbling about why are you doing
this to americans
like i
i can't say america's sweetheart but
will smith wait may as well be
bro
what happened on i got into a different
kind of entanglement i think um you need
to say clearly what happened and i got
into an entanglement with
august that's what i said
an entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely why
why would you agree to do this
on the internet
will you have a say
you have to say you don't have to be
here
run we decided that we were going to
separate for a period of time and you go
figure out how to make yourself happy i
was in a lot of pain and i was very
broken
now in the process of that relationship
i definitely realize that
you can't find happiness outside of
yourself
and luckily enough
you and i were also going through a
process of healing in a much different
manner i would during that time launched
into an interaction
with august what do you feel like
you were looking for
i just wanted to feel good
it had been so
long
since i felt
good what does that mean
husband now i got to be with you at the
press conference while you like to tell
the world
about your transgressions
like i love i love my baby i'ma stand by
my baby no matter what no i definitely i
definitely understand
why it would look that way or feel that
way but i actually don't look at it as a
transgression at all through that
particular journey i learned so much
what
oh my god she doesn't even regret it
why would you do this to the man
about myself and was able to really
confront a lot of
emotional immaturity emotional
insecurity and i was really able
to do some really deep healing
it was really a joy
to just
help heal somebody yeah
because i wasn't sure i was ever going
to speak to you again i know i know yeah
like
the fact that i'm speaking to you again
is uh
is a miracle i want to go through this
no more yeah no i don't either yeah
i'm gonna get you back first and then
you're gonna get me back i think you've
got me back
i think you've
i think we're good on that okay
okay i wish
does that mean he cheated too is that
like
is that what they're saying
you know
i wish that wasn't the case
i do
that wasn't the case
here's the thing people on the red pill
be like will smith leave you could do
better he totally could but from his
perspective like if he leaves his wife
that's a family dynamic with like his
wife and his for two kids
he will never get back
ever
but yeah you picked wrong when you were
like 25. she could be all magic and
miracles yeah
that might that's probably true you know
but
um and i don't think it's about getting
anybody back no for me it is okay
um i'll give you that petty that's what
you want
um but you know i will definitely say
it's just part of it yeah you know if
you expect to be with somebody for a
lifetime 25 years and counting hmm
we ride together we gotta go together
bad marriage for life
[Music]
i definitely think they're less cute now
i kind of wondered if something was off
in their relationship when i when willow
talked
because like her
i remember before this even came out
like she was talking about like open
relationships and stuff and like how she
wanted to be in like a throuple and i
just felt like no
girl with like a stable house
would want a throuple like i would never
in a million years even if you're gay
like you want to be
that's just weird um
but let me know in the comments what you
guys think
that was kind of wild um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell and i'll talk to you
guys next